hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna talk
about a show I've been watching on HBO
called the night of this video we'll
couple cover the first half of the
limited run series the first four
episodes and will contain spoilers of
everything that's happened up to this
point the night of is a story of a young
man's journey through the criminal
justice system in New York City our main
character is Nasir Khan who goes by NAS
who is a college student born in the
United States to Pakistani parents we
get a brief appointed introduction to
Naz in the first episode where he
appears to be a pretty good kid he's
close to his family he works hard at
school he appears to be helping or
tutoring an athlete there and we really
don't notice anything that seems out of
place during this opening sequence nos
and his friend get invited to a party
and there's a promise that there will be
a ton of girls there nas decides he
wants to go but his friend stands him up
at the last minute not wanting to miss
out he he you know in the party he
decides to take his father's cab to the
party and that seems to be completely
impulsive on his part either way he
drives into town and gets lost because
he doesn't know how to turn off turn on
the off-duty light for the cab a young
woman jumps in the back wanting a ride
Naz was in the process of trying to turn
the light on because two guys had
already gotten to the cab before that
and he couldn't figure it out and in the
meantime Andrea jumps in he initially
tries to get her to leave the cab too
but she ends up being able to persuade
him
she's like flustered and it looks like
something happened we don't really have
any insight into what it was I mean you
know Naz never asked they ended up going
down uptown to sit by the river where
she gives him a hit of ecstasy at first
he tries to refuse it but again she's
able to you know talk him into it and
take it because she tells him I can't be
alone tonight they go back to her
apartment start drinking and she has him
snort some powder that looks like
cocaine he's definitely messed up as
he's someone who doesn't drink or do
drugs and she gets him to stab her in
the hand with this knife that they were
playing a game with I mean she had it
out because she was cutting up limes for
their shots but either way he ends up
stabbing her hand after that they go
upstairs and we see them getting naked
and getting into bed they start having
sex and then next time we see nas he's
passed out with his head on a table that
we later find out is in the kitchen he
has a glass of water next to him but
other than that we don't know how he got
there how long he was there or anything
else he just basically comes to so as he
comes to he heads back to the to the
bedroom to get dressed and go home
as he's getting dressed he tells Andrea
he's going to take off but she doesn't
answer he goes over to the bed to tell
her goodbye only need to find her dead
and covered in her own blood he panics
runs downstairs leaves the house
realizes he doesn't have his keys runs
back to the front door only to find out
he's locked out breaks the window to get
in grabs his jacket sees a knife on the
table picks it up and then he runs back
out to the cabin Lea one of her
neighbors hears the window breaking so
he ends up seeing Naz running back to
this father's cab and then he calls the
cop
Naz makes an illegal turn that gets him
pulled over around the same time that
the call goes in so this all ends up
with him in custody the cops finding the
knife another witness showing up at the
station and identifying that Naz was at
the scene and Naz getting charged with
killing Andrea whose body was found at
the brownstone when the police went
there to check out do you know the
break-in so the big question is what
happened between the time we last saw
Naz awake and when we see him come to
Andrea was definitely killed we learned
later that she had been stabbed 22 times
and the police can definitely put him at
the scene on the other hand he hasn't
shown signs of being a rage killer and
their encounter seemed like both parties
were into it and that it was 100%
consensual as viewers we aren't thinking
he did it but there haven't been very
many other characters who could be
potential suspects that we've been
introduced to either in fact through the
first four episodes there's only a few
people who stand out as possible
suspects so let's look at them all
individually suspect number one the
hearse driver after Naz first picks
Andrea up they stop at a gas station
while he is inside pain she tosses a
cigarette butt out the window which
catches the attention of this guy who
was fueling up a hearse at the next pump
over he walks over picks it up and
knocks on the window he asked her if she
wants to be his next passenger as in do
you want to die and ends up putting the
cigarette out like against the window
when she ignores him when Naz walks back
out they showed the driver in the frame
again watching him as he gets into the
car the scene stands out because the
driver is a bit creepy but really we
have no other reason to think
would be involved in the murder it is
not unbelievable that he would have just
been annoyed by the fact that she's
thrown that cigarettes out her window
while he's pumping gas in order for him
to be the killer he would have to follow
them to the river and then back to her
place where you'd have to wait until the
right moment to sneak into the apartment
and that might not seem that hard to do
but let's not forget he's driving a
hearse which is pretty noticeable it's
like a pretty note so be it vehicle and
it stands out for those reasons I would
be shocked if the hearse driver is
actually the killer suspect number two
unknown guy on the street the next
seemingly non-essential character we
meet as outside of Andrea's place as
they're going inside two guys walking
down the street say something under
their breath and that causes Naz to ask
them what they said the one guy Trevor
eventually steps up and tells him that
he said something about leaving his
bombs at home and Andrea intervenes
before things escalate Naz and Andrea go
inside but we get this long lingering
look from the second guy on the street
who doesn't say anything during the
exchange he looks pissed and it's
notable but we don't have anything else
about we don't know anything else about
him when Trevor shows back up later
after the police arrive he ends up
getting pulled in as a witness and the
second guy isn't with him we don't have
a lot to go off here but there is a
slight possibility this guy could turn
out to be the killer the way Detective
box gets Trevor to cooperate to be a
witness is by saying that he knows he
has weed on we know Andrea does drugs
and she may have had some interaction
with these guys in the past it's a
stretch but it's possible if there was
more than we know and there was some
sort of relationship between the second
guy and Andrea we might have a motive if
you know he saw her with Naz and that
set him off people who think he did it
also point out that Trevor lies about
him being by himself when he saw them
the you know the two of them in the
first place but you can easily explain
that away by him not wanting to pull his
friend in to what you know he's talking
to the police about if he said that he
was with somebody else and the police
would want to know who that is and then
they would want to talk to him too so
it's not surprising to me that he wasn't
mentioned that he was with somebody well
he is a stronger suspect than the hearse
driver we would need some big
revelations in order like to find out
that he was the killer for sure suspect
number three the motorcycle guy as Naz
is driving away after he
Andrea dead a motorcycle rider pulls up
next to him at the first light he stops
at he's the the drive the motorcycle
rider stands out because he looks over
at him but other than that we don't have
any idea of who he is or if he's
important or not people theorized that
he might be connected to the murder for
the same reason that some people think
that the hearse driver might have done
it because otherwise why are they in the
show in the first place one difference
here is that he pulls up next to NAS and
Naz has the knife right on the like on
the dashboard from the crime scene so
you know he has to make a decision and
he decides to put it in his jacket since
you know the rider is looking at him
this isn't very strong evidence so
unless he turns out to be someone
important and we find out his identity
later I would say there isn't enough to
say that he is or isn't the killer
there's also like a theory that involves
the fact that if you look really closely
at Andrea's driver's license she has a
motorcycle thing on there so you know
there may be a connection but the just
seeing the guy he doesn't really do it
for me suspect number 4 The Stepfather
detective box has to contact Andrea's
next to Ken who happens to be her
stepfather at first he refuses to come
down saying he's tired of dealing with
Andrea and you know basically her
problems with the law box explains that
he needs him to come in and that the
situation is serious we find out that he
wasn't married to Angie his mother for
very long and then we find out that
Andrews mother is actually dead they
don't seem very close I mean the
stepfather and Andrea but at the same
time it seems like Andrea must at least
turn to him when she's in trouble
because she doesn't have anyone else we
learned from him that she has been in
trouble a lot that her problems are
related to drugs and that she has a lot
of boyfriends none of this is a very big
surprise considering what we see from
Andrea before she's killed but there is
also something that feels a little bit
off about the stepfather when he first
gets there and is supposed to identify
the body he seems really relieved that
he can just look at pictures rather than
looking at the actual body however when
he looks at the pictures he says they
aren't her and then he won't change that
answer until he finds out if it's not
her then he needs to look at the body to
be sure one part of the scene that
stands out for me is when he's staring
at the microphone that
in the glass window there's a woman
behind the glass giving instructions and
it's sort of like he's you know that the
situation's setting in for him it stands
out that he's like you know absolutely
affected by her death even though he
seems to downplay any closeness that
there was between them now is this
suspicious I don't really know but it
definitely gives you you know makes you
want to think about like what their
relationship is the stepfather is
definitely connected to Andrea of course
and there is a scene at her funeral that
further puts the spotlight on him as a
potential suspect as people as everyone
else is leaving he's still standing
there by the cast at talking to some guy
that we don't know it boils down to a
conversation about money and the
stepfather tells him to sign the papers
and send the check and says don't call
me again the stepfather looks angry and
threatening and stone records all of
this on his telephone so it may come up
later other than that we don't know a
whole lot about where the you know alibi
if they really had a different kind of
relationship that we know so the
evidence isn't in as far as saying the
stepfather did it he's a pretty good
suspect but that's all we know suspect
number five gnaws himself is the killer
the police feel like they have enough
evidence against Naz to get a conviction
he's the only one they know was there
they found him fleeing the scene with
the bloody knife in his pocket
was so few other suspects and scant
details about any of them I started to
think that maybe Naz really did do it it
would be a big surprise and after he
passes on the deal to plead guilty I
thought maybe the big twist of the
series was that he did do it but he
would end up getting off anyways then I
went back and watched the first episode
again and realized there are some real
problems with this theory first and
foremost we know Andrea was stabbed 22
times and we saw how much blood there
actually was when Naz wakes up at the
table he doesn't seem to have any blood
on him at all you could say maybe he
cleaned himself up took a shower and
then passed out but later in the police
station we see that he still has blood
on his hand presumably from when he
stabbed her you know the first time
downstairs when they were playing with
the knife if this was the only thing you
know that might explain you might be
able explain that away by saying that he
got that blood on his hand when he broke
the window to get back in the house but
it isn't the only thing doesn't add up
when you think about NAS being the
killer if you think he did it think
about some of what happens afterwards I
won't even get into the details of the
crime scene or the evidence or the lack
thereof since we haven't actually been
given that much of that to go off of
just based off what we seen Naz would
have had to stab her that many times and
then clean himself up all before he
passed out this would mean that he
blacked out either as a result of the
drugs or some mental illness he has we
don't know about and that means it makes
it seem less likely that he would have
had the you know the sensibility to
clean up remember when he first
discovers her in the bed he doesn't know
that she's dead and he ends up running
out of the house without the keys he
grabs a knife that isn't the murder
weapon and takes it with him when he
comes back and then for some reason
picks up the bottle of coke or whatever
it is - none of this is the behavior of
an experienced
killer who has it together enough to say
be a secret serial killer or something
like that one more thing is that when
when he gets undressed at the police
station and we see the scratches on his
back it also looks like he has a smear
blood from her hand above his hip this
will be consistent from the women that
she suffered before they went to bed
when they were playing with the knife in
my opinion this is really clear evidence
that he didn't clean himself up at all
before he goes and passes out at the
table one of the main reasons I thought
it might be nos is because the other
suspects we've been presented with
seemed like they had been red herrings
or they were just people that were added
to mislaid mislead our way of thinking
after looking more closely at the
visible evidence we have though it'd be
really hard for the showrunners to make
NAS the killer so where does all that
leave us then halfway through the season
have we just not met the killer yet or
will it turn out that it is actually the
stepfather well one of the other guys
it's hard to tell and while I think it's
important that we find out what happened
on that night maybe overall that isn't
the point of the series the night of is
based on the BBC series Criminal Justice
I haven't watched that because I didn't
want to know what the end might be but
the name criminal justice seems to be a
foreshadowing all of itself everything
that's happened in the show since the
actual murder has revolved around the
truth that nas doesn't really have a
chance whether he committed the crime or
not he's at Rikers Island completely out
of his element and the other inmates
know that his charges include aggravated
sexual assault as Freddie tells him with
this charge and killing you know the
fact that he killed a girl it doesn't
matter if he did it or not either way
he's a marked man stone actually comes
through for him by
and stop talking to the detective in the
beginning but but we see that he really
doesn't have the experience or resources
necessary to help Naz if the case
actually goes to trial Allyson Crowe
getting involve seems like a really good
turn of events but then she ends up
pulling her offer of doing the trial pro
bono after he doesn't plead to
manslaughter and do the fifteen years
and all along the way we see glimpses of
people that aren't actually being
completely truthful with him he gets
slashed by a knife by a passing inmate
and then has this cup of hot water and
baby oil thrown on him by someone who he
thinks is his friend it's hard to tell
the Freddy's interest in him is what he
says it is or not we see that he spots
him coming into the jail and pays
attention to him right away which might
support the story that he tells him but
Freddy is obviously operating from a
position of power inside so we don't
really you know you can't really tell
either way nas ends up stuck with him
because he realizes that going in alone
isn't going to get any better
so is this show just a bit of social
commentary on how messed up the justice
system is in the United States there is
a part of me that hopes so because I
think it's pretty accurate as far as how
the system works for poor people
trials cost a lot of money from both
sides which means that the state has an
incentive to overcharge people they
can't that they know can't mount a good
defense this gives them leverage to
force a guilty plea for a lesser charge
like the plea that was presented to nas
instead of gambling with a jury who
might find the defendant guilty on all
charges or suggest a maximum sentence
for a case like nas who has in mind
as a minority has less chance of being
judged by a sympathetic jury pleading
guilty and giving up 15 years of your
life could be the safer choice as many
people told him before he decided to
turn the deal down and go to trial think
about the effects of just being charged
that have already had on his family I
mean his father can't work his brother
can't attend school the new news has
been camped outside of their house all
of this within a culture that is
supposed to have a justice system where
you were innocent until proven guilty
even if NAS was somehow able to get out
of the situation both his his and his
family's character and standing had been
destroyed I think it's safe to say that
just being charged with aggravated
sexual assault and first-degree murderer
enough for most people to write you off
if it is that if it is a commentary on
the problems of the justice and
correction system I would be okay with
it because I think the show has been
hundred percent engaging up to this
point and it makes me think that the
clues room the conclusion will be
satisfying I think it's an important
conversation to have as well I mean
despite some less than significant
details I think that everything that
they're showing here is an accurate
depiction of a reality of what a kid
like nas would be up against I'm
interested to know what you guys think
though do you think we will find out who
killed Andrea if so who do you think it
was do you think we'll find out but the
damage has already been done so nas will
go to prison for life anyways do you
think this is a realistic depiction of
what would happen to a guy like nas in
the system or do you think it's an over
dramatization let me know what you think
in the comments and tell me what you
think is gonna happen please like the
video and subscribe to my channel if you
want to see more videos like this thanks
for watching talk to you soon